él es secretario de seguridad nacional
alejandro mayorkas se dijo en un
comunicado que en estos tiempos
extraordinarios en ucrania eeuu se
simpatiza y apoya a los ciudadanos
ucranianos en este país en este sentido
pues se aprueba el estatus de protección
temporal conocido acá como el tps que le
da entonces a los nacionales ucranianos
en eeuu la posibilidad de trabajar
legalmente y la posibilidad también de
no ser deportados esto es importante
porque pues precisamente los ciudadanos
ucranianos acá pues van a tener la
posibilidad de quedarse en este país y
no ser deportados a un país en guerra
eeuu normalmente da el estatus de
protección temporal a países que están
en guerra que pasan por una crisis de
desastres naturales o por otro tipo de
situaciones extraordinarias en estatus
de protección temporal por ejemplo se le
ha dado a una cerca de 12 países entre
ellos venezuela nicaragua el salvador
yemen y sudán entre otros países bueno
cristóbal y cuantas personas se verían
beneficiadas por esta medida
si se calcula que en este momento en
eeuu hay cerca de 30.000 ucranianos que
podrían verse beneficiadas por esta
medida
específicamente 4000 ucranianos que
están en proceso de deportación según
informan autoridades y otras organismos
que se usan este tipo de deportaciones
4000 ciudadanos ucranianos que están en
proceso de deportación serían los más
beneficiados esta medida llega después
de mucha presión por parte de el
congreso tanto de demócratas como
republicanos para pues brindar este
estatus de protección temporal hay que
resaltar sin embargo que los ucranianos
que lleguen en las próximas semanas a
eeuu no podrán aplicar esta medida no
aplica para estos nuevos refugiados que
lleguen en los próximos días a eeuu sólo
será aplicable a los ciudadanos que ya
están viviendo en eeuu a partir que
estuvieran viviendo en eeuu a partir del
primero de marzo de este la medida ha
sido bien recibida por críticos tanto
republicanos como demócratas
en el congreso y en otras esferas de
washington para precisamente seguir
apoyando a ucrania y seguir mostrando un
rol de liderazgo como dicen muchos
analistas de eeuu tiene que mostrar en
estos momentos